Mass Effect Andromeda z' combat has seen
some fundamental changes from the series
previous games
you're more mobile with the help of your
Jump Jet powers can be combined for
brutal combos and glasses are no longer
really a thing but don't worry we've got
all the hot tips on how to make your way
through Andromeda's dangerous world if
you're interested in some more general
advice for the game check out tips to
start your journey in Mass Effect
Andromeda and sub for even more videos
let's do this with no class restrictions
you're allowed to put points into every
skill sometimes you need to invest a
certain number of points in that tree
for some of the heavier skills like
biotic charge to unlock but you will
eventually unlock everything you won't
however get enough points to maximize
everything my recommendation put one
point into every skill and mess with all
of them
find out which skills work best for you
and then head to the tempest med bay to
respect yourself for a small fee now you
can invest more heavily in the skills
you want it's easy to overlook them but
don't forget about profiles the base
user profiles is the percentage bonuses
they give soldier improves guns engineer
improves tech skills adept and proves
biotics you get the idea the best way to
handle this is to pick the skills you
want and then assign the profile that
fits the best profiles also increase in
rank the more skills you invest in a
tree the really cool aspect of the
profiles though is the bonus abilities
they give engineer as a combat drone to
assist you
infiltrator cloaks you while evading
which makes it a great pairing with the
cloaking ability but it also lets you
see enemies through walls while scoping
making it ideal for sniping
my personal favorite is Explorer which
replaces the evade with a biotic blink
letting you teleport through most
objects take the time to play around
with what profile works best with your
skills and weapons once you have a set
of skills and the profile pairing you
like set them to your favorites from the
profile or skills menu this allows you
to quickly switch between four different
styles on the fly mid combat just be
warned anytime you switch the powers
will be on cooldown all right let's talk
power combos pulling these off deals
high damage and looks awesome so you
really want to build your loadout
surround these there are skills that act
as combo primers and combo detonators
reading the power descriptions will tell
you what skill is which and gives you
some good starting suggestions for
example combining pull and throw simply
hold down pull to bring them towards you
aim and then press throw
this is by far the most fun combo for
its sheer comedic value and multiple
applications maybe get a little target
practice with your sniper rifle and it
doesn't just work on enemies but the
many explosive containers lying around
as well
it's just hurling people into space
isn't enough for you a quick biotic
charge as your third skill and launch
yourself after them and if they're still
not dead finish him off with a ground
pound biotic charge pairs with other
skills as well cryo beams will freeze
enemies in place and well you get the
idea
let's talk my favorite skill the
flamethrower it's great for dealing with
groups and the best way to bunch
everyone together is with a singularity
singularity will work great with any
ability that does radius damage such as
concussion blast
speaking which if you toast with the
flamethrower and then hit with a
concussion blast it creates a nice bonus
explosion doing all these fun combos
requires enemies to lose their shields
or armor first so it's not a bad idea to
make your third power overload energy
drain or incinerate there are dozens of
skill combos so let me know some of your
favorites and for more in dromeda videos
watch our mini documentary series of the
story of Mass Effect Andromeda and check
out our full review
[Music]